neutralité religieuse de l'état on sait
à quel point cette question a déchiré le
québec pendant des mois mais le
gouvernement a choisi de ne pas aller
aussi loin que le parti québécois et sa
fameuse charte des valeurs
oui c'est sûr qu'au jeu des comparaisons
le projet de loi déposé aujourd'hui par
gouvernement couillard apparaît me par
rapport à la charte des valeurs
proposées par gouvernement de pauline
marois
prenez simplement le titre du projet de
loi c'est la loi favorisant le respect
de la neutralité religieuse de l'état
c'est même pas le projet de loi sur la
sur la neutralité religieuse de l'état
alors c'est s'explique de deux façons
par la proche surtout du parti libéral
le fait que le parti vert à une approche
légal
face à cette question alors que la
proche du parti québécois était une
approche de valeur mais la proche légal
du plq donne lieu à des contradictions
apparentes par exemple le plq comme
parti n'accepterait pas une candidate
qui portent le tchador parce que c'est
un objet de soumission de la femme nous
a dit philippe couillard il ya un an
mais comme gouvernement le gouvernement
de philippe couillard refuse d'interdire
le tchador pour les emplois de la
fonction publique parce que il veut
respecter ceux qui par choix portent le
tchador
respectez donc la liberté de religion il
y a là une contradiction apparente on
est dans la nuance
évidemment mais la proche du
gouvernement s'explique aussi par le
fait que en terme de neutralité
religieuse de l'état
le gouvernement estime qu'elle est déjà
bien exprimer elle est accepter et les
respecter cette neutralité et que des
gens qui portent des signes religieux
ostentatoires ou visibles ne font pas de
prosélytisme qui n'essaie pas de
convaincre d'autres personnes d'adhérer
à leur religion
j'aimerais qu'on dise un mot quand même
sur les questions du discours haineux et
sur la radicalisation parce qu'on a le
sentiment que le gouvernement allait
pouvoir un peu limité en tout cas en
matière légale
le code criminel encadrent le discours
haineux le gouvernement du québec peut
jouer sur le code pénal donc avec des
amendes pour les gens qui propagent des
discours haineux mais aussi un constat
c'est que tout est à faire pour
documenter les discours haineux au
québec pour documenter la radicalisation
et tout ça va tourner beaucoup autour du
centre de la lutte contre la
radicalisation de montréal qui va
documenter le tout qui va avoir une
ligne téléphonique aussi pour les gens
qui vont avoir besoin de conseils
mais on a l'impression en effet que
c'est relativement limité comme pouvoir
pour le gouvernement qui est très clair
comme toujours merci c
bonne soirée